la guerre des ordinateurs pour attaquer
lempire de bill gates
apple vient de sortir un appareil à la
fois sophistiquée simple d'utilisation
et beau imac ou quand l'informatique
devient un jeu d'enfant dominique vadel
pascal bernier c'était le 15 août
apple lance aux etats unis son tout
nouvel imac des ordinateurs en veux tu
en voilà
cent cinquante mille vendus en huit
jours et paraît-il des ruptures de stock
monstre coup de pub ou coup de bluff ou
réalité
qui sait mais voilà en tout cas de quoi
redonner espoir aux constructeurs
longtemps menacée de quoi redonner aussi
des couleurs à ses fans historiques du
mak désespérée de la quasi hégémonie du
standard fait c'est ces dernières années
ça c'est original au moins ça ressemble
à quelque chose qui vient d'ailleurs
près de paris aussi des cartons sans
piles pour les toutes premières
livraisons françaises design monobloc
forme ovoïde et couleurs acidulées ont
été retenus pour cette machine avec
unité centrale intégrée
il suffit juste de la brancher
directement sur une prise téléphonique
pour se balader immédiatement sur
internet dont on attend presque des
miracles
le développement d'internet sera notre
vecteur principal on voit aujourd'hui
que les gens s'abonnent massivement
quand il achète un micro ordinateur à
internet ça c'est un phénomène nouveau
pour la france
ici depuis quatre jours jean-françois
avant le nouvel ordinateur en avant
première une centaine de machines
auraient déjà été commandés encourageant
dit il est peut-être la fin du cauchemar
pour son constructeur
ça va stopper l'hémorragie des clients
là qu'ils achetaient du pc qui migraient
vers le pc dans le doute il faut à
savoir si apple est sorti 2
de la crise on la crise chez apple on
vous l'ignorez sans doute par
superstition et avec cet imac qui
ressemble tout de même un ultime va-tout
ou vise même très en danger de mort on
est sorti aujourd'hui d'une rue
sortie aujourd'hui de cette spirale
qu'on soit très rapidement revenir 10 6%
pas de marché 10% cela voudrait dire
tout simplement triplé les ventes
mondiales au détriment bien sûr des
constructeurs pc
bref rallumer la guerre mac pc qui
serait sans doute une nouvelle fois
celle des prix
[Musique]